conventional attractiveness has zero
predictive power for long-term
relationship success what the [ __ ] it
doesn't matter how loudly or how many
times you say that i'm pretty sure it's
been said many times before and it's
only getting more and more unimportant
how are you feeling after your weekend
gig playing uh champagne supernova to a
massive crowd of uh 18 adults and five
children
uh you know i
i feel like a celebrity you know just
walking into a party picking up an
instrument
and singing an absolute classic that's
by the way like i i said that that night
like that has got to be a staple if
you're trying to just have a sing-along
song
really any oasis song we've determined
the champagne supernova in the uk if you
to ask it in the uk it would be a bit
cheesy because everybody already thinks
that like to put wonder wall or don't
look back in anger or champagne
supernova it's so obvious but i said it
in america and everyone was like yes
amazing idea i'm thinking
the first thing that came to mind
wonderwall
wonderwall is
it's like that here
okay so that is a corny one to choose if
you gotta pick up a guitar and you start
playing wonder wall you're gonna get
[ __ ] for it 100 because it's just like
you know you know the meme where it's
like the conversation ends and you go
anyway here's wonderwall
you know yes so that it is it is a
widely known thing just like don't play
wonder wall but champagne supernova
that's not off limits you crushed it man
it was good yeah we had a i had a great
saturday i went to lift atx this new
indoor outdoor gym that was fantastic
it's a bit hot like it's very hot austin
generally man i want to wait to
guatemala right so i'm in guatemala uh
getting the visa thing and then i come
back and something's happened someone's
flicked a switch in austin and this
place is disgusting now and it's about
everyone's like oh just wait until
summer arrives i don't want to wait
until summer arrives this is already
far too much for me
yeah it's at a certain point it's either
like you go from ac unit to ac unit
or ac unit to pool
you know to shower like to acu yeah
you don't want it you're not just like
doing outdoor activities and not having
like
air conditioning near you well for sure
everyone in england knows most people in
cold places understand that you want to
dress appropriately and spend as little
time in the cold as possible moving from
you know a heated car to a heated house
to a heated office to a gym or whatever
but the reverse just is so bizarre it's
like oh you don't want to go outside
it's too hot
it's never been a problem i've always
wanted it to be more hot but yeah so uh
did lift atx that was cool
went to see everything everywhere all at
once with sky because it's it's to do
with asian stuff so skye was in love
with it and uh
for the people that haven't seen it
it's pretty cool i don't think it's
the best film ever made which tons of
people are sort of giving it that
accolade but yeah pretty good
the one assessment you said was like it
wasn't um
like uh like deeply sci-fi enough right
i just thought it was gonna be more like
tenet or
interstellar or something that was gonna
blow my face off and it was funny and
and
quirky and it had charisma and stuff but
that for me that detracted away from the
serious whatever philosophical undertone
of it and then i asked a bunch of the
guys everyone had a different idea about
what it meant and no one agreed with
anyone else about what the under like
the subtext of the of the plot was uh
and then we went to our boy chase's
birthday he played wonderwalt and then i
went to a new nightclub so this weekend
was pretty pretty fun man i got a lot in
yeah
yeah that's just gonna be the typical
weekend for someone who's now a visa
holder in the states yes that's a big
deal you can't just you can't just
glance over that that's a big deal man
you're here now
can come and go i want to fly in and out
right yeah there you go literally yeah i
mean that was getting the 01 is is such
a um
it was such a journey like
700 pages
to get that portfolio submitted and you
need signatories and you need
offers of work and you need a sponsor
here in the us and all of these it's so
weird like it literally would have been
easier for me to fly to mexico and walk
over the border i'm pretty sure that
that would have been a civilization just
being illegal yeah that would have been
an easier solution
it's done man yeah probably
i'm here now um
i
was watching that cariakos grizzly video
that you did where he talks about
training for the difficult
yes what what is that
well i i think
first off kiriakou's grizzly is he is
he's an enigma
he is very very strong but he does these
unusual movements that are not very
functional i guess would be the
definition he he does like zercher
shrugs so he'll like
literally stand with weights in his
elbows like a barbell in his elbow with
an obscene amount of weight and he'll
just like shrug it up and down two
inches okay and then he'll put it down
and start screaming he's also a very
very large individual like part of his
training is just like getting on the
scale and it says like 195 kilos body
weight and it's like you know it's like
a a thing that he's passionate about is
how heavy he is he's in and what what's
interesting is
what happens with a lot of the fitness
industry around youtube
and i can i can list off examples but
these guys
they're kind of you know enigmatic like
i said but then they kind of get memed
and maybe someone thinks they're stupid
or foolish at first but then they just
keep going long enough to where
it's yes it is this under
said joke right it's like kiriakos
grizzly like we all know what's going on
but at the same time the joke has been
going on so long that like you're an
[ __ ] if you don't go along with the
joke
and i absolutely love it like i can't
get enough of of this guy so
what he says is two things he says you
have to live it
and you and then the other one is
training someone says why do you train
so hard he goes for the difficult
okay
okay
it's amazing it's amazing if you're
gonna if you can think of like a greek
accent someone going like for the
difficult you know it's it's not like
grammatically correct but yes it's for
the difficult
and i perceive it as you know just
giving yourself adverse adversity so you
can create a better version of yourself
uh but what i did was i kind of
deconstructed that and and tried to make
a video that i could help people with
and um
there was this really good example that
i used of jack white who's like one of
if i look up to anyone in music it's
it's jack white
and one of the things he said in this
documentary it's a great documentary
it's called under these great northern
lights and
it's him and meg white and the white
stripes and they're going uh through
canada and they just go through like
really random places and play live gigs
but one of the things he says is like um
convenience
is the enemy of creativity and
being if you are given all of these
opportunities it's it's less likely or
if things are made easier for you it's
less likely that you're gonna make
something that you're gonna see as
worthwhile and one of the things that he
says is like you know for instance
you know book four days in the studio
and make yourself make an entire lp
which is a full-length album and uh a
couple of you know one of the things he
says is like
if i go up on stage and i just kind of
play what we usually play and i don't
show that effort people know
whether they
whether they say that they know it
there's something inherent where they
can tell
that you're just kind of
just going through the motions so what i
try to do is make things difficult
you know a lot for the difficult and so
he's like i play these 15 year old piece
of [ __ ] guitars that go out of tune
their string snap i play them because
it's an added challenge i put my picks
on the amp behind me rather than on the
microphone stand so if i drop a pick i
have to during the song find a point
where i could sprint back and get a pic
i make the piano
a distance away from me
so when i switch from the guitar to the
piano i have to sprint over there i have
to time it up just right and if i don't
i'll miss it and he's like i add all of
these challenges in
so that
i can create something beautiful for
people to watch
and uh and i i liken that too for the
difficult i try to you know i try to
take something that's meme worthy and
see what we can learn from it i usually
do that sort of sort of thing with my
videos
um another example of this is actually i
think i think it was david goggins on uh
rogan
and he i believe he said he's like i'm
gonna go back to work joe like my hands
are getting too soft and he said he
wanted to do like smoke jumping
which is um
like forest fire uh fighter
or something like that i i can't
remember the exact and if he actually
ended up doing it he's like you know my
life has gotten too easy for myself he's
like i gotta make it hard
and so like i always think about those
things it's like am i making life too
easy for myself are you out there making
life too easy for yourself what can you
do to make it so it's more difficult
but still able to move forward
goggins hasn't done any media in three
years i found this out last week he
hasn't done any new media
like in three years he's done little
bits for his own channel but he hasn't
you know
someone like him breaks onto the scene
and you would expect to see him on rogan
once a year and he would be doing rounds
sort of constantly
and he hasn't done anything for three
years which is
pretty wild so maybe he has been
training for the difficult maybe he has
been doing whatever hundred percent
knowing that guy he has to be he has to
be
have you read his book i've only i i'd
never read it when it first came out by
now i'm listening to it now dude it's so
good
and uh this guy had such a [ __ ] up
childhood it was ruthless his dad was a
pimp that ran a roller skate rink and
they he used to
make the kids sleep in the office
because they would be catching up and
oh dude it was it was terrible
absolutely awful and then his mum was
about to marry this guy and this guy
dies and he was finally gonna have a
family and then he doesn't and then just
an endless number of
catastrophes that happen and then
there's all of that stuff about him
cleaning out cockroaches it's a super
inspiring story i get that he's not
everyone's cup of tea because of the way
that he communicates but yeah
he's he's fantastic man i i'm really
looking forward i think he's going to be
doing more stuff this year i think he's
going to be back on it this year um and
if that's the case it's like
there aren't many other people that do
what he does even jocko who's you know
kind of close to him in terms of his
rhetoric
it's not the same like jocko does the
joker thing and goggins doesn't go into
things so i'm i'm glad that he's he's
maybe coming back uh what are your hold
on what are your thoughts
on poking your head out every once in a
while when you're when you're at that
level maybe david goggins isn't quite at
that level but what are your thoughts on
the less is more approach
to maybe social media to whatever that
may be
well robert greene talks about the fact
that a little bit of aloofness creates a
sense of mystique and sort of attraction
around who you are because if people
always know that they can get a hold of
you as much as they want
i don't know it doesn't seem as special
anymore um
it seems to me that it's probably just
like any other normal distribution right
that if you're going to post very very
consistently online and put out tons and
tons of content you have to be an
outlier in terms of the quality so james
smith's a good example of this right he
has
i wouldn't like to guess the last time
that he went 24 hours without his story
being up and it's always tons and tons
of stories and they're always face to
camera and they're always
there's always something happening right
but he's an outlier because he's
interesting like he's a he's a funny guy
that has great delivery online so he can
get away with that now
i think it would probably be a bit of a
waste if you had james's skill and
decided to only do it
every three years do a little batch of
of runs
there's definitely something exciting
about only getting like a a limited run
of access to someone's ideas um and
something tells me that
maybe with goggins
he's he's probably the sort of guy
that's going to have
enough stories and enough amazing
insights to maybe do that to do like a
condensed run every three years and then
go away and then prove himself for the
difficult and to then come back and be
like look here's what i learned having
done the difficult
here are some more things for you to
learn about but if it was just
consistent i don't know whether that
would work quite so well you know i mean
yeah there was that period
when jordan peterson came back after
he'd had you know basically two years
off from his recovery and all of that
stuff people were excited because
they hadn't seen him for ages and
yeah absence can sort of make the heart
grow fonder maybe like that
what do you think
well i i like to think about tulle one
of my favorite bands um
maynard keenan being the lead singer
like
even when even when they perform he's in
the back so it's like the only lead
singer i've ever seen that goes to the
back of the stage behind the drummer
no it's like kind of to the left or
right of the drummer but in line with
him
yeah
and uh sometimes actually behind the
drummer so like danny carey i believe i
can't quite remember because i saw them
live is
probably one of my top three favorite
shows i've ever been to and danny
carries more center stage and he has two
boxes that he goes to that are to the
left and to the right of danny carey and
maybe even slightly behind him so you
can already get that mystique from him
you know and he was also saying like as
far as sound goes it's easier for me
uh to to sing and it makes more sense
just because i'm a singer it doesn't
mean that i should have my back to my
band um but
you know he's a type of guy like that
band to me is so massive but yet they
have like almost zero pop culture
uh
wha what sort of like explosion
yeah their relevance right they're just
not relevant in in pop culture and yet
they can sell out arena after arena
after arena after taking a massive break
from album to album and he goes and he
takes this money from this tour and he
[ __ ] off to arizona to his winery and
he just all he focuses on is is making
good wine and now he's gotten into like
this uh industry of trying to sell his
wines to other restaurants in arizona
he's trying to build like this hub
that's what he's passionate about and i
think i just find it so interesting when
your art is that good
that no matter what you do if you start
a tour people will go crazy for you
and i almost
revere that because i'm in the position
of the opposite and i believe you're
probably the same
right where it's like if we don't
if we don't show poke ourselves
yeah if we don't feed the beast we are
disappearing
and so it's almost like yeah the grass
is always greener but
um i i do respect it i think it's very
very interesting to talk about i also
think especially with maynard keenan and
tool and who's this other one perfect
circle right that's his other one
yeah and pussyfur and but yeah perfect
circle yeah um
those guys are people that have
done the work and got themselves to the
very top something tells me that when he
was first starting out that he wouldn't
have been able to be quite so aloof they
were probably play playing more shows
releasing more records being more
available for doing press and for doing
stuff like that this is a conversation i
had yesterday
in the uh
at the pool party of the w hotel like
not the place that i thought i was gonna
have a great philosophical conversation
but i ended up having a great one with
joshua and um we were talking about the
fact that a lot of the time
people look to those that are successful
and have made it
ask them what their advice is or what
the ways that they operate are now and
then try and map that to someone who's
not at the same stage of the journey so
take a look maynard keenan probably
nailed shows he had to learn how to tour
to perform live to deal with on stage
nerves
everything right the logistics the sound
the quality all of the things that you
need to do
you only really get that from iterating
on your craft from doing things over and
over and over again but if you were to
ask him now or if you were to try and
model his behavior now you'd go oh
there's this sort of aloof thing that's
going outside bro no one knows who you
are but maynard keenan can do that
because he's may not [ __ ] keenan
right you don't get to do that is
starting out band member
that nobody has a clue what you do
i i've seen the same thing if you want
to learn how to do something like so for
instance uh in the sport that i'm
involved in olympic-style weightlifting
people look at the elite and they base
their training off of what they perceive
the elite are doing now
right they may not even have an
understanding of exactly what the elite
was doing they might have a few clips of
what they're doing and say oh they do
this i want to do that as well two of my
most successful videos in youtube
history for me
both over 3 million views are exactly
about this thing is modeling your
movements your behaviors off of the top
is actually one of the worst practices
you can do rather than trying to model
your behaviors over someone that might
be slightly more successful than you
because that's much more attainable and
that's much more realistic of a
direction for you to go and then you
just keep on taking those small leaps
and you make realizations about your
process and how you would get better
over time uh rather than looking at
dimitri klokov or uh liu zhao joon both
of like the most famous weightlifters on
youtube and on instagram and saying oh
they do this i want to do that well it's
like you didn't see what they did yeah
do what they did decades before do what
they did when they were at your stage
not when they're at that stage
exactly i mean it's that same we would i
can't remember the example i think it
was warren buffett where he talks about
how
um
i think it's 60 percent of berkshire
hathaway's wealth has come from 10
trades
in his life
10 trades bro wow to make more than half
of the
uh gains from berkshire hathaway i mean
one of them is coca-cola
uh and
there was this
wild story where he worked out the
proportion of real estate inside of
people's stomachs that coca-cola needed
to take up in order to be able to get
itself to the place that it want they
wanted it to be um so he you know he
really really really researches this
thing and he takes forever to make a
decision and blah blah blah blah and you
go well yeah that like that's that's
really really great but i also
seem to remember that he did a ton of
businesses when he was in his teenagers
he was
um yeah selling newspapers and cleaning
cars and doing loads of stuff and he got
okay like that's what he did when he
started out what are you doing when
you're starting out and i i really think
there's something there
about
mapping the journey not mapping the uh
successful strategies of people once
they've reached that end destination or
that that sort of pinnacle thing uh
speaking of which monkey parks you
worried about monkey pox
i haven't i i've only seen just like
memes monkey pop
monkey
is real so monkey parks outbreak is
primarily spreading through sex world
health officials say uh european nations
have confirmed dozens of cases in what's
been the largest outbreak of monkey
parks ever on the continent according to
the german military i don't know why
they're involved in this the us has
confirmed at least two cases and canada
has confirmed at least five so it's the
building belgium has introduced a
mandatory 21-day quarantine for monkey
pox if you get monkey pox and covid
you're [ __ ] um
the most recent surging cases appears to
have been spread among men who have had
sex with other men so the first place
that this came out of was a sauna in
madrid so there's obviously
i don't know a bunch of guys maybe
having a bit of fun in the sauna
and then one of them is i mean i i want
to know this is always the question
like who was the person that ate the
pangolin or whatever or the one that
escaped from the lab or some [ __ ] what
is it zero yeah patient zero patient
zero yeah i wanna know who i wanna know
how monkey parks come because it's not
interesting are you sure are you sure
you want to know yeah i can't are you
sure
i kind of do i don't want to see it
graphically definitely not but i do i'm
pretty pretty intrigued but yeah so
vaccines are available um but
it's it's just fascinating that you're
talking about how many cases there are
in europe and then there's this
uh it's sexually transmitted a new
sexually transmitted infection while the
virus itself is not a sexually
transmitted infection uh which uh
generally spread through semen and
vaginal fluids the most recent surging
cases appears to have been spread
amongst men who have had sex with other
men uh emphasizing that anyone can
contract monkey pox many diseases can be
spread through sexual contact you can
get a cough or a cold through sexual
contact but it doesn't mean it's a
sexually transmitted disease okay so
that's interesting so it's not actually
an sti but it's just
it's just one of the ways that you can
that you can contract it but yet now
this is the new this is a new current
thing that everybody needs to be
concerned about
okay well clarify that for me because
maybe i'm just an idiot and didn't
understand that
can you get it from if you are not
sexually active with other men or
sexually active at all can you get
monkey pogs
yes yes
okay
all right
so it's a chickenpox it's a
it's a it's now a virus
is there a
potential for a cure or are we looking
at it they've already got a vacant
stomach or they've already got a vaccine
there's a vaccine that already exists
for it um
monkey pox is disease caused by a virus
in the same family as smallpox but not
as severe monkeybox can kill as many as
one in ten the vaccine used to prevent
smallpox appears to have an 85
effectivity rate guarding against monkey
parks in observational data and research
in africa world health officials say the
vaccines aren't widely available so it's
important to reserve them for
populations that are most at risk
what does that mean
what does most at risk mean like the
people that are just like the the
biggest players like the ones that are
able to slay
like hey
hey look who's the chad in this city
come over here we got to inoculate you
like you did yeah i gotta head to cvs
man get get myself a vaccine real quick
because uh i've been getting a lot of
action your boy [ __ ] that's why yeah
cause your boy [ __ ] uh i don't think
that it's going to be an uncontrolled
spread in the same way that we've
tolerated the covert 19 epidemic but
there is a possibility that this has
gotten into the community if in fact
it's more pervasive than we're measuring
right now that becomes hard to snuff out
and they were concerned that this summer
because of all of the different
festivals and stuff that were going on
uh that people were just gonna be
spraying their monkey pox everywhere
yeah they're just gonna be going
everywhere
spreading that spreading that pox
did you get chicken pox yeah yeah i've
had it did you so yeah so i had it so
there's something about the dormant
uh what's i don't know what the um the
virus is actually called uh but it's
like it stays dormant in you and then it
can
like it can wake up i guess um does that
know what shingles is is that not what
happens yeah but i thought i thought
that shingles was adult chickenpox so if
you hadn't had it as a kid and you don't
have immunity ooh
i'm pretty sure that that's what it is
because it's kind of dangerous to not
have had chickenpox as a kid
yes no i think i think either one so it
it's it's pretty much dormant for the
rest of your life certain circumstances
can make it you know wake up
and then you get shingles but i don't
know dude monkey pox just i mean sorry
it sounds funny well it sounds so it's
so weird because like chicken pox we've
just accepted that as oh that's just the
name of it monkey parks oh
what a ridiculous name
how dare you put an animal in front of
the word
yeah exactly it's a it's a new one uh
johnny depp trial man have you been
watching any of this
uh mainly again dude this is this is so
pathetic because i feel like all of my
answers oh have you heard about this
it's like oh either i heard of it
through a meme or i saw a 25 second clip
to maybe a three minute clip
on instagram or uh tick tock maybe i am
just one of the the herd you do know
that that's how
pun intended that is how most people get
their news now in fact that probably
makes you better informed than most
people okay well you know i like to
consider myself you know
above
yes so so
yeah what i've seen is actually i've
somewhat loosely followed the herd
controversy for a while
um i know i heard like some horror
stories earlier on and then as far as
the trial goes i've against just seen
clips like the clip of amber heard
supposedly snorting cocaine during
which is you know
maybe she's doing that maybe not the
fact that she uh took a [ __ ] in her own
bed but it was on johnny's side
uh it'll teach him
yeah
that'll teach you
crystalia had a difficult great bid on
that
crystalline is like hey don't [ __ ]
in your bed
your own bed
the funny thing like i just want to know
like what position she was in
like was she was she squatting over the
bed like her feet were on the floor
or was she on the bed squatting
she was holding on to the backboard
you've got to be on that you've got to
be on the bed in full squat that's the
only way okay so so what so she's an
experienced third world squatter
because that's not an easy task if
you've never [ __ ] she's got good
mobility
maybe she should consider transitioning
to the sport of olympic weightlifting if
she can get herself all the way down to
the bottom of a squat
yet honestly her mobility is good enough
now to to work with her i'll i will dm
her and see if i can start working with
her um
i know that you've got
some bigger fish to fry at the moment
but once you've completed this court
case have you ever considered entering
into the sport of olympic weightlifting
uh ms heard this could be
your
journey back into because i'm not sure
if you're aware there is 4.5 million
signatures
on change.org to get amber heard
replaced in aquaman 2.
really dude 95 4.5 nearly 5 million
people i think if it breaks
it's already one of the top uh
petitioned
changes ever right and i don't know what
the title is in fact like i'm gonna i'm
gonna work this out what is the most
petitioned
change.org
but to to you know
miss heard look i just realized that in
order to efficiently [ __ ] you sorry
sorry is justice for george floyd
perhaps unsurprisingly uh 19 but that
was 19 million people dude
one quarter of the number of people that
wanted justice for george floyd want
amber heard to be removed from aquaman
oh my god come on
world
yeah
uh misheard i realized that in order to
[ __ ] in your own bed
uh you would have to have the mobility
to you know stand on a relatively
unstable platform mind you
uh and and squat in what we would
consider a deep squat position something
that's very optimal for the sport of
olympic weightlifting uh in order to
defecate on your own bed so given that
information
you have the prerequisite to be
a very fine athlete
um how would you mind coaching from me
uh we'll take you to the top of this
sport
if you are listening if you are
listening we got it but dude
here's another thing as well yeah this
has happened before that people want
because it takes so long to film a movie
and then to edit a movie and then to
publish and publicize a movie
it's like
do you realize how much work it would be
to replace amber heard shot for shot in
a movie that's already been filmed what
do you want to do
they did that with crystalia
well yeah but he wasn't one of the
central characters or was he true yeah
that's true i i guess i didn't care
enough about aquaman like
again bringing up crystal leah this is a
chris leonard this is a great bit he got
someone's like hey man i watched aquaman
and
and my response is
what plane did you take
because you only watch aquaman on the
plane and that's actually how i feel
about it it's like i don't really care
about it that much i had no idea that
amber heard was in it yeah
because because to me it's
it's
you know that there's a bit in there
there's a bit in the trial where johnny
depp suggests that the only reason that
amber heard got the role was because of
him
so the the
prosecution
uh the other attorney is saying to him
you didn't want amber heard to do any
movies did you you didn't want her to go
out and have meetings did you and
johnny's like no didn't say that at all
i mean
how do you think she got the role for
aquaman of course i'm supporting her
you're like
[ __ ] so he's suggesting basically that
the only way she got it was through that
and uh yeah dude i it's this whole thing
is wild you think about the fact that
they're both constantly recording each
other
think about that like there's all always
recordings of each of them talking about
stuff can we please bring up evidence
number three two two one seven you know
okay where's this come from oh it's one
of them recording the other one like
some secret agent [ __ ] oh wait audi like
audio recording yes throughout the whole
trial
knew this was coming
i don't know why they were recording
each other that's my question but what
is it that's you know no look look this
is it it's a it's you know when you get
into some sort of a toxic relationship
it's more important to show burden of
proof of the other person's wrong doings
later on
you know it really i mean if you get
into it it's supposed to be off his face
all the time i don't know whether he's
got that i i don't know what they were
doing it for maybe it was in case
there's a court case but there's
recordings from 2015 and [ __ ]
yeah i mean when i don't dude people
change when they get into really really
bad relationships
they do they do things that they can't
even i mean i've been in bad
relationships and i've done things where
i'm like that is not who i am
like you know raised my voice like
something like recording someone else to
to then garner some sort of uh advantage
leverage on them later on
that's absolutely possible especially
from someone who's not the manipulated
one
it's like oh well this is the standard
that we've set for this relationship yes
you know it's like i can go sneak and
look on your phone because that's just
what we do now i can yell as loud as i
can at you because we've done it once
we've done it a couple times we can all
do these things i i really think like
that's the mark of
the worst possible relationship is
saving issues so that later on you can
use them as ammo agreed yeah i mean
you're also seeing now what happens
behind the doors of people that
johnny depp seems to have come out of
this
he's super charming he seems like a
really sweet guy
amber hood seems super manipulative
uh but you can't say that it's a healthy
relationship from either side
this isn't this isn't a very nice
relationship or a good relationship to
be in but you're right what happens when
someone
does something when there's a first
mover and you begin to think oh well
this is the tone of the relationship
that's been set now okay so she did this
i'm gonna do that and then i'm gonna
keep this one in my back pocket in case
she brings up a different thing and then
we can start that tit for tat game i did
a video about sam harris ages ago about
how i thought that this was a this was a
big deal that you have this sort of ever
increasing intensity spiral of tit for
tat and words for worse for worse or
worse and that's how relationships end
up like tons of relationships i've been
in end up like that but it's just what
happens when you see people
who are
super super highly strong
johnny it sounds like was on a
a good bit of drugs and all sorts of
different other
uh
addictions and [ __ ] that he had too and
he was falling asleep by the side of the
bed and doing all sorts of things
you go well when you layer all of this
together with some ego and a 300 million
dollar net worth
yes nailed it um
also
kate moss is giving
evidence this week
and amber heard apparently was dating
elon musk
at one point and then there was another
time that james franco came around to
the house it's like just a litany of
i don't know weird famous people that
are getting drawn in so what do we what
do we think why don't we get pamela
anderson pamela what do you think about
this we'll get you in as an expert
witness for this particular cake people
that i didn't think would have anything
to do with it but apparently they do
yeah well you know like it's just the
i love the take that i see it's it's on
so many comments it's like hollywood is
not real these people are egotistical
narcissists and
no one really cares what they do it's
almost like we watch to uh see the
demise of it
you know but
there's always someone who's like
why do we give a [ __ ] about the
hollywood elites they're not real
they're the scariest people on earth
because they're
they like they're just represented
they're just all everything they do is
character caricature of something yeah
well i think i would i would go i would
probably say that what i've seen at
least of johnny depp either johnny is
one of the finest actors that's ever
graced the planet or that's really the
way that he is you seem very consistent
throughout the trial like he's super
calm super chill but with amber heard
you do see that real discordance between
maybe the person she thinks she's
supposed to be the person that she's
playing all of that was really
uncomfortable and um
yeah i don't know
there's this whole group of people at
the moment um
who's machine gun kelly scene at the
moment who's that chick thingy fox megan
fox
jennifer fox jennifer
megan megan [ __ ] jennifer fox
so like they they were in the news the
other week because they were doing blood
rituals like swapping blood yes um yeah
i'm pretty sure that johnny depp said
that they'd done something similar early
on in the relationship
and then dude it wouldn't surprise me
i'm if i could put money down right now
jared leto is going to have
something come out about him within the
next five to 10 years
oh yeah i mean it already has become
that for sure they're um
the way i was made aware of it was uh
phillian
video
yeah so that that's where i was made
aware of it he is
wildly creepy when they uh compile all
of these interviews and these weird
things he said and
yeah i would not be surprised either
that's a great call that's i i would
give you you know
odds just about it
yeah
i don't know man there is something
about this that just makes me think
but then you also think about the fact
that the uh
who is epstein's enabler who was the
chick that he did that with uh jalane
maxwell julian maxwell case not
publicized at all
no uh daily trial no video none of that
johnny depp and amber heard it literally
is just like someone waving the big red
flag like look at this look at this
don't look over here don't look over
here not allowed to look over here
that stuff pisses me off so much man
it really really does like they're just
the silencing of
things that can damage and hurt people
that aren't in hollywood but are in
majorly powerful positions
not just in the us but you know
worldwide being the
economy that we are the the powerhouse
economy
it's
that that stuff is ridiculous when you
start going down that rabbit hole it's
just only frustration from from there on
out do you know what's really
frustrating as well is
how quickly the internet seems to pivot
from uh hashtag metoo to hashtag men2
that that now i understand that men too
is a response to the me too being over
like potentially overblown in some
people's eyes and that the amber heard
johnny depp trial is look men can be the
victims of dv as well they can be the
people that are being socially
manipulated psychologically manipulated
they can be hurt he nearly had his
finger chopped off when she threw a
vodka bottle at him
but
it doesn't add in what people haven't
realized is look
that particular style of thinking
believe all women was maybe a little bit
too low resolution right as has been
shown in this case in front of us
doing the opposite
doesn't suggest that it's any better
like that's just as low resolution
thinking
but see that is this not just
how everything in the world works
you can't just go
absolutely this is the team absolutely
this is the team and just let the
pendulum swing back and forth
yeah like like uh foam finger holding
that's what i call it you know the
people that go to the game they just go
that's my team the liberals the
democrats or you know the republicans
conservatives like that's my team i root
for them no matter what
um
yeah and then the pendulum swinging is
just nauseating you know um i saw this
movie men yesterday was it any good uh
i
i don't know uh
it was by it was by alex garland who
made x machina and um
uh annihilation two of like movies that
i really like
it was pretty good it was you know uh
thrilling but the story behind it or
what it was mentioning was you know the
faults of men
that aren't being taken by men you know
so it's it's more along the lines of the
metoo movement it's like um there are
characters in it that treat the main
character
like every
uh
you know patriarchal trope yep the nice
guy you know the nice guy trope there's
like the gaslighter there's like the
sexual worshiper and it's very obvious
in that way and the funniest thing is
i'm watching this and from my
perspective i could see seven different
characters of females because i've been
in situations where the opposite has
happened to me
right so it does not it's not oh believe
all men believe all women it's like
believe some men believe some women but
you know like or don't believe any of
them until they prove themselves or how
about this things are not a storyline
things will always remain gray the best
stories
are actually the best movies are the
ones that are like
this must be the good character right
this must be the good guy this must be
the bad guy and then all of a sudden
you're like wait the bad guy i cannot
understand why he did that oh the good
guy like why is he doing that shitty
thing you know it's like those are the
best the ones where you question
the characters and in doing so you
question yourself
and i've always found that sort of thing
fascinating but it's infuriating
like you said to just see the pendulum
go from one side to the other
i see it on every social media platform
but it's easier right it's easier to
have low resolution thinking all that
you need to do is go well here is a
one-size-fits-all answer you see this in
the red pill community as well they've
got their answers for what what it is
that women are after you go well
i don't know man like that doesn't fit
with my
experience of women in the real world
and maybe i just happen to have managed
to live 34 years and have a really
unrepresentative experience or maybe
there's something about me that's
selecting for a different type of of
people that i speak with but i've met a
million people stood on the front door
of nightclubs that's a pretty big sample
size met a lot of women right working in
nightlife and they they would be the
ones that would be thrown under the
buses oh well they're the most club
bratty hoey
low
moral girls that you're going to find
well
didn't seem that way to me so
yeah what what do you but no no no it's
significantly easier to just have a
one-size-fits-all answer because you
never ever have to question your
assumptions again
yeah and um
i the
the boys versus girls girls girls versus
boys
on tick tock instagram you know anything
is just incessant it is non-stop
it is you know it's it's always a
one-size-fits-all thing
and what what's problematic is
if you do it if you disguise these
things these these binary
understandings of of you know left right
whatever if
if you disguise it with memes and with
clever funny and timing it's all about
timing doing it first and being funny or
it's all about being contrarian if you
disguise all those things and someone
calls you out and says hey man what
about this gray area you go oh it was
just a joke dude take it easy you know
are you really gonna say that all men
aren't bad at a time like this it's like
well why can't i you know or or vice
versa not all women are bad at a time
you know when something comes up so i
always think that that that happens and
it's just so prevalent in social media
it's like
you really got to cut through all of
that well you've got to think um
certainty and black and white thinking
and a pithy well-rounded snappy tagline
sounds a lot like
wisdom and insight and understanding
like that's a good proxy for those
things it's not those things but it
sounds like what someone that actually
knew what they were talking about would
say
and i think that that's one of the
reasons that it catches fire online
because a platform like
twitter or tiktok specifically isn't
built to have longer form discussions
it's built to optimize for pithiness
right it's built to be optimized for
shortness so what you end up with is not
necessarily the argument which is the
most right it's the one that is the most
believable or sounds the most right and
that gets
filtered through all sorts of things
people use fluency as a proxy for
truthfulness so that's why the people
that have great delivery presidents that
have amazing eye did not have sexual
relations with that woman like
bill clinton got away with all sorts
because he had [ __ ] great delivery
so okay
how do you sort of pull these things
apart and yet you have an entire
internet of people that are able they
have way too much spare time
but people still get seduced by the same
things
do you feel like the internet has
evolved into this thing where it's all
about relatable it's all about oh
like my face when you know like my face
when this happens or like
i feel like almost
all of tick-tock is
is relating a life experience to other
people and maybe that's how things have
always been but it's
meme and meta culture has literally
taken almost every single aspect of the
internet at this point you're the expert
on tick tock man that is one of the
things i'm so glad i'm not that i didn't
i haven't developed that compulsion you
know of all of the other
addictions online that i've got i'm so
glad that tick tock wasn't one of them
i'm slowing down for sure i'm definitely
slowing down um it was definitely really
intriguing at first but i always observe
it through a critical lens
like i'm always
criticizing whatever the idea is but the
girls versus boys boys versus girls
thing there's problems on either side of
that debate and
what i'm able to do when i look at tick
tock is observe the comments
see where i disagree decide what you
know rather than a lot of people it's
just confirmation bias right it's just
oh i believe that thing they did a
really funny video
uh
that was quirky and been timed up really
nicely with my life
let me just repost it to my instagram
story really quickly
okay that
i believe that things like that
uh can eventually do more harm than good
and that's not why i use tick tock i
just use it
to just observe and see what's going on
in the internet there are some really
funny just
stupid comedy viral videos still so i'm
always down to watch stuff like that but
it is a good platform for observation
twitter on the other hand is something
that i don't think i could ever get into
interesting i don't even know if i
really tried yeah i quite like twitter
speaking of which i got sent this thread
by rob henderson earlier on which is
really interesting could the matching
imbalance on tinder and other dating
apps be a factor in the rise of the
incel movement and young men reporting
low sexual activity so there's a graph
here that says the
young men share of men and women between
the ages of 18 and 30 reporting no sex
in the past year and that has gone up
from 10 to 30 percent
for men
since
uh around about 2010
to 2020 to now right so over the last
decade the number of men reporting no
sex in the last year has tripled and the
uh line on the graph has got where
tinder's introduced and it is exactly
when
men
uh where that that inflection for men
beginning to go from the 10 percent to
the 20 to 28 percent women also actually
um stay flat for a little while but have
increased
which is also very interesting um wealth
in tinder is not distributed equally
attractive guys have more wealth in the
tinder economy they get more likes than
unattractive guys that's the bottom
eighty percent of men bottom twenty
percent of women top eighty percent of
women top twenty percent of men think
which a lot of people are familiar with
um there's a thing called a guinea
coefficient or a genie coefficient which
works out how much inefficiency there is
within a system so it's used to look at
economies within countries uh and the
lower that the number is the um
more equality there is uh within wealth
distribution so
if modern dating apps were a country it
would be one of the most unequal in the
world the tinder economy has a higher
genie coefficient than 95.1 percent of
the countries in the world it's just
below south africa
it's above venice it's disparity
yeah it's above venezuela and just below
south africa that's where it sits uh
according to open source data a man of
average attractiveness can only be
expected to be liked by slightly less
than one percent of females 0.87 on
tinder this equates to one like for
every 115 females and men in the bottom
10 percent see just one match per week
at most
ultimately most women only swipe on a
handful of men per day while men are
more freewheeling with their swipes so
yeah men females pass on 95 and like on
five and men are basically 50 50 left
and right um
it's just
so we
we had talked about tinder before
and
one thing that i think is actually
really interesting was
before tinder
there were websites like eharmony you
remember that
um
and the way that the way that we looked
at it you know the the guys in my friend
group the people my age we looked at it
as like oh what a weird [ __ ] idea
online dating super weird you're weird
like it's it was just kind of like what
the hell and then here's tinder this fun
little swipey thing it's kind of about
hookups it's everyone
it's a meme right it's it's a it's a
it's like a meta commentary it's just
like this is hilarious
we're swiping it's hilarious we match oh
what's up like
and then almost immediately after that
online dating becomes something serious
it becomes something like well i haven't
gotten any dates let me go online there
was really there's really not much
resisting
to whether it's cool or not you can
resist whether you want to do it or
whether it's legit or not or or if the
masses are doing it but if someone says
hey i'm on hinge
or i'm on tinder they're not going to
get made fun of because it's just the
masses are doing that whereas eharmony
and match.com like if you had done that
at the time where they were very
prevalent for i think older generations
um it was definitely seen as a weird
thing that's the same as anything though
right there's adoption adoption curves
but it was but it it wasn't
like e-harm it wasn't like we all jumped
on eharmony
we all jumped on the hookup app
that made this
the location services was i think the
thing
you are in the same location as that
person here's a picture of them
do what you want with it
rather than this kind of weird um almost
like my spacey type of
aol vibe to it which you would get from
eharmonyandmash.com yeah maybe on the
tinder thing you get this more you get
this handheld
you know location services this app on
your device that good user experience
separates it
why do you think it would be that the
introduction of tinder would
increase the number of men reporting no
sex you think it's just women do you
think that what this guy's implying in
the thread is because of this high
inequality that women are sort of
wistfully chasing after the eight out of
tens and above for guys and they're not
giving any attention to the dudes at the
bottom because you would have presumed
maybe if you hadn't been able to work
out what was actually going to go on
everyone's talking to everyone more that
should facilitate more casual sex for
everybody overall but what it seems has
happened is the gains have been
sort of accrued to the very few
super chads at the top and then there's
this big sexless underclass of men that
is now 30 of men reporting no sex within
the last year
yeah i mean more matches for the female
would mean
uh
you know why would you take the
male that you're less attracted to
right like why would you take the
opportunity if you know you can match
with more and more and more and more
people you're going to leave out a very
large chunk of other people where men
apparently do not have that option
so yeah i mean it's they're just chasing
after the potential match that they know
is more likely going to happen
maybe if those two people meet like
this is also another thing women are
and men are now looking at their
potential mate through the lens of looks
whereas before
you might not think someone is
attractive until there's some sort of
action that makes them attractive
whether that's someone in your class or
uh you know someone you go to the gym
with or whatever
that interaction is what makes them
attractive and
then you're looking at someone who if
you saw their tinder profile or if you
saw their hinge profile you would not
have swiped
so maybe that's occurring less
you know
potential mates like
you just had on a guest who said that
the worst
quality to look for for a long-term
relationship is looks conventional
business yeah and that is exactly what
people are looking at when they get
these apps well i think that this
probably explains
a big chunk of why
relationships are now increasingly short
and this is something that people don't
necessarily see so it's easy to say um
there is now a global sexual marketplace
um anybody with an instagram account or
a tinder account can basically be in the
entire world's
sexual marketplace right they can be
dating somebody in guatemala or bali or
germany or wherever they want
and therefore that means that people are
mate switching more easily because the
friction of doing that is
lower and because the number of
competitors for whoever your mate is is
significantly higher now and that women
will lilly pad from one guy to one guy
from one chad to one chad to the next
one
now the thing that seth stephens
davidowitz said that was really
interesting is that the algorithms can
predict what you're going to click on
unbelievably well they will be able to
predict with like insane accuracy
whether you'll swipe left or right on
someone and the algorithms can do
basically nothing to work out whether or
not you'll have long term happiness and
whether a relationship will last long
term so
for the people that didn't see the
episode
um the
things that are most often used as cues
for whether or not someone will swipe
right or left are things like height
conventional attractiveness wealth level
and job right those are some of the the
most common things that are used
these have
zero
basically zero correlation with whether
or not a relationship is happy long term
those things were psychological
stability conscientiousness
um a growth mindset a bunch of other
things
none of which can be displayed on a
tinder profile i can't tell whether
you've got a growth mindset or whether
you're uh somebody that's
psychologically stable yep precisely in
fact you might be able to try and signal
precisely that through your looks and
then have the complete opposite you can
put window dressing up as much as you
want so my point being that
what people are doing now is optimizing
for the wrong parameters people are
optimizing for things which are
completely arbitrary when it comes to
long-term relationship happiness for
girls things like height i think it's
something like
eighty percent of women on hinge have
their height limits set to six foot or
above for men
that's
less than 10 percent i want to say less
than 10 or 15 percent of men in the
united states are above six foot and yet
that and
height has zero predictive ability
when it comes to looking at long-term
relationship happiness imagine you
saying to me dude i only date girls who
are a size four and a half shoe
i'd be like
why
why i know that this has no it bearing
on whether or not you're going to be
happy in this relationship but you just
pick this arbitrary thing because it's
become captured by the culture that
girls that the size four and a half feet
do you know what i i have a great i
almost have a
reasoning for that having and this is
anecdotal but i i feel as though
girls hold more of an animus towards
these dating apps
so that they say
look if i'm gonna get on hinge i'm gonna
get the best of the best and if it
doesn't work
no problems for me i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] if i get one match if
i get 10 matches i don't care
i'm on this thing
to not get [ __ ] over but i if i'm
gonna get someone they better be tall
they better be good looking they better
be this this and this where
maybe it's not the the same approach for
men
right i i i can honestly say that i've
heard many many women just say like it's
almost like the dating app owes them for
being because they resent the fact that
they may be they resent the idea that
they're there yes
that's interesting absolutely that has
to be it right i mean and then men are
on there because it's like well [ __ ] i
haven't gotten laid i'm not sure that it
has to be i think that would be
a really interesting i want a mate or
something like that and i really hope
this works
you know i don't think
i think it's less likely that a male is
going to be on there and be resentful
for it
i don't know man a lot of guys seem to
be very resentful of online dating as
well now well they don't they don't like
it but i think their approach to it is
less of uh well if i don't get the best
looking girl i don't give a [ __ ] oh yeah
well
that's inevitable because the fact that
guys are the
um they're the protagonists and girls of
the gatekeepers right that's always the
way that
that it's going to be it's you know i
mean hinge first hinges design
hinges designed the whole um novelty
around hinge is that it flips that
imbalance on its head because typically
it's the guy that messages first and on
a hinge it has to be the other way
around i think no that's bum that's
bumble bumble is
bumble
yes bumble but you know what it is
that's the one i meant right yeah where
you go well the power dynamics being
shifted because for precisely this
reason because to avoid girls from
having too many incoming messages from
guys that they whatever like erroneously
accidentally swiped right on or some
[ __ ] but yeah man it's um
it's really interesting i i i just don't
feel very positive i think about the
world of online dating at the moment i
just don't see it getting any better you
know i even had logan yuri i had hinges
director of relationship science
on so she's a lady that's in charge of
looking at how the apps facilitate
relationships long term
and she had some great points to put
across she's very keen into intentional
dating being deliberate with what am i
looking for why is it so on and so forth
but the apps simply can't get around the
fact that people
tend to optimize for the wrong
parameters now they tend to optimize for
stuff that doesn't have any predictive
power and how would you create an app
that was able to gauge someone's growth
mindset or their psychological stability
so did you see the black mirror episode
no um where okay so this is fantastic
they basically it's two people that go
to this
this or
this camp thing or whatever it is and um
what the what happens is the algorithm
or the machine pairs you up with someone
and then based off of your date they
determine how long you are to spend with
that person and sometimes
it says you will be with this person for
the next six months you will be with
this person for the next six years you
will be with this person for the next 12
hours and at the end of it you
absolutely must
change partners
and um i'm spoiling it so i don't care
it's been out for like seven years yes
it's an episode of black mirror
and what happens is
this guy ends up falling in love and
then they say you are only to be
together for like the next four months
or something like that i don't know the
exact thing and if you break the rules
like you you are not allowed to break
the rules it's kind of like this sci-fi
feeling to it um
and then what happens is they have to
break up and he says [ __ ] the rules [ __ ]
all this we're going to escape together
and so he grabs her and they make this
big run away from the camp or whatever
and they climb this big wall and then
everything just dematerializes around
them and what they realize is or what
you realize at the end is that they were
just a couple of ais that were running
through a machine to see if two couples
in real life not in this ai world that
they created were uh meant to be
together they they went over all of the
things that the intangibles that can't
be done in an app
so this is this would be something that
you would have to do you'd have to
create a very scalable ai version of
other people and be able to match them
and put them through the real test
the longing for one another when they
can't be together like put them through
the real test and if they and if it ends
up working out in that little ai world
you'll say this person is a 97.1
match so on and so forth you want to do
that would be the only way to do that
simulated tinder
it would be yeah but the problem is that
you
you know you have the these ai they live
these conscious lives only to fulfill
our needs
to to find the right mate but i i would
i mean you're right it's we
as of right now we can only look at
these simple ass metrics that really
aren't that important it's usually just
what they look like like you said their
height
physical attractiveness what they can
write in a bio
and what they can write in a bio is it
clever enough to make me giggle can they
break the ice right when they message me
all [ __ ] that doesn't matter two years
into a relationship and you gotta figure
out who's gonna you know take care of
certain things around the house and all
these things none of that [ __ ] matters
yeah or it's a pandemic i don't know how
it's a pandemic
you need to work out how you two are
going to deal with being apart from each
other or living in a house together with
each other like going back and looking
at someone's tinder profile and
comparing that with the
what you know right now yeah precisely
oh my god yeah and it is it is so
bizarre when you think about it like
it's all window dressing and none of
these things that you're looking at in
the window are actually things that
matter for long-term happiness
conventional attractiveness has zero
predictive power for long-term
relationship
success
like
what the [ __ ] what it doesn't matter how
loudly you say that it doesn't matter
how loudly or how many times you say
that i'm pretty sure it's been said many
times before and it's only getting more
and more important yeah yeah
yeah it is and also there's like on both
sides of the fence here it's
increasingly for all that the sort of
body positivity movement and
that sports illustrated cover has come
out and this is what fitness looks like
from self.com and the future of
healthiness or whatever it was on
cosmopolitan for all of that like
i don't really see
anybody on the apps actually changing
their personal preferences it's like oh
okay so you're happy
to share this front cover on your
twitter account
and yet you're still swiping left and
right on exactly the same people when it
comes to your own personal preferences
be careful what you say chris
because uh you're spitting facts and uh
it is very funny it's like oh you really
are accepting of all body types but when
it comes to dating apps all of a sudden
uh you don't want any pardon that
um but yeah i mean look this is really
funny because i just saw this today it's
tim dillon uh basically he's saying it
doesn't matter the organization they
don't
when they grow to have enough power and
enough um eyes on them they can never
care about you as an individual
and you know those people that are
putting out um
you know the this is beautiful and all
these virtual signaling things is like
if you are truly about that cause give
all your money to charity
if you are truly or or show you know you
they just utilize it purely as something
that would drive clicks
that will you know jordan peterson did
more for that sports illustrated
uh magazine than anyone else could have
they dude the ceo or the editor-in-chief
for sports illustrated should go and
thank jordan peterson they probably
haven't had that many clicks in ages
for [ __ ] sake i clicked on it i was
like whoa oh [ __ ] the the this the
swimsuit edition is out let's see what's
going on here
i want to see who the woman is that he
thinks is is not attractive of course
i'm gonna do that you know
it is so it is you're so right man like
they must be split testing what gets the
most clicks for this
the fashion companies that are using
plus size models you'll notice that they
never use skinny fat guys
so they'll have normal dudes oh my god
did you see this the other day so it was
so funny one of my guys one of my guy
mates tweeted this from the uk about how
it was um
different types of underwear one was for
men and one was for women and the women
was women of all sizes and the dudes
were shredded out of existence and it
was just like a comparison of the
women's underwear and the guys underwent
all of the guys were absolutely ripped
bro that that
kind of sucks dude
that kind of sucks like look i i guess
maybe it's not masculine of me but to to
have that be the standard for men and to
not be like hey it's accepting it's
acceptable for a man to do that because
hey look like
um someone you know said this the other
day and and it was a woman she said like
you know i sometimes misinterpret
this we can give as much [ __ ] as we want
to men because they're men
you know it's like we misinterpret it
it's like they should be able to handle
that
you know we have looked at a society
where you know we look at through the
lens of the quote-unquote patriarchy and
so we
dude i've just put it in the chat
have a look have a look at this thing so
have a look at the difference between
it's maya
and the women's the women's lingerie and
the guys lingerie wait this is the exact
same is this the same page or did they
cut it no this is the same page
[Laughter]
you know what what does that [ __ ] say
man what does it say to to men it's like
oh yeah like
you guys don't need to be babied at all
ever you don't need compliments you you
know oh your feelings are hurt well
you're a man can you tell for the people
that are just listening can you describe
the uh the image all right so look
so look we have the women of all sizes
on top uh we have women of all ages for
sure on top you know we have an older
lady on the right a couple older ladies
in the middle and ethnicities as well
all ethnicities men
shredded shredded shredded chicken
absolutely dick skin peeled
uh okay well looks like we have
uh a couple different races here uh and
then shred it well no it's not a couple
of different races there's only one like
slightly caramel guy but that's the same
dude twice oh that's the same dude
twice
great homeboy in the middle is ready to
step on stage he's peeled out of his
mind yeah
this is not uh yeah
the acceptable
but this is interesting they have um
this is different brands so are they
pulling from
are these like meyer uh models or what's
the deal here i'm not sure sometimes
sometimes uh e-commerce sites will have
their they'll get products from a bunch
of different brands then they'll shoot
it in their style right like asus does
this asos has asos models even though
they might have night clothes so it
doesn't really matter that it's
different brands
this is [ __ ] up now how [ __ ] wild
is that
it's so blatant
but anyways to finish what i was saying
is just like this this idea that you
know this woman had brought this to my
my attention she's like you know i i do
tend to just not really give as much of
a [ __ ] about men's feelings because it's
always we're worried about we are
worried about women's feelings and a lot
of times we can brush it off and that is
a mistake that i've i've made and i try
not to make anymore and you know it's
the same thing here it's like well
we have to absolutely worry about body
dysmorphia in men because the moment
that men begin to think that their
bodies aren't as acceptable as they
could or should be they can develop
problems that
you know us they usher out into real
life
we've seen this in in bodybuilding in in
my world in fitness like the people that
are constantly commenting on another
dude's body
like they do have problems within their
their own worlds this isn't just men
towards women it could be women towards
women or men towards other men and it
happens a lot of men towards other men
but dude think about what what we said
on the last one which is slut-shaming
the amount of slut-shaming that goes
from women to women the amount of people
who are anti-abortion or pro-life
by and large it's women the vast
majority of uh comments that are done
about other women's appearances done
from women to women and yeah like
this is where the whole battle of the
genders thing yeah you can't you it
can't just be this thing where it's like
men
versus women or women members of women
or women versus men it really is
problematic and i it's so [ __ ] weird
it's like i had this realization on tick
tock because it's like the gen z kids
the kiddos out there like you're
noticing a lot of women who are just
like they
they're playing on it they're not
actually serious but they always
vocalize it's like having a crush on a
woman now like me women are much more
vocal about being sexually interested in
other women because of their disdain for
men in general because we have the men
versus girls girls versus yeah i'm sorry
yeah men versus girls girls whatever you
know that that war going on between the
two of them it's just so apparent and
the same could be said at on the
opposite side like the the the idea of
oh she's for the streets you know what i
mean like what's up i mean the the i
it's like um
if a if a woman you know does something
that's [ __ ] she's for the streets oh
okay pick your head pick your head up
king like focus on yourself yeah yeah
yeah as it's that's like the the meme
language that kind of surrounds it and
they both have their flaws you know but
it's it's
it's always it's
for me the only reason i'm bringing it
up is because like i don't see that
changing
and i think you you told me this before
you like uh that's where you you have
your issues zac is that you call to
action a culture shift which is just
like an almost impossible task yes i do
that a lot on my videos i go i wish as a
culture we could do this thing better um
or i'm pointing out this flaw in in some
sort of fitness charlatan and i'm i'm
wishing that we could do this thing
better and for some reason i forget what
your point was or who brought it to your
attention but it's like calling to
action this massive cultural shift is
not always the answer it's not even
remotely the answer it will never work i
just don't think that it's realistic
because you don't have like a god's eye
coordination for this you know what you
would need to do would be able to sit
everybody down
and say look
here are some interesting insights guys
and girls about where you think your
oppression or your vulnerability or your
difficulties come from and a lot of them
are calls that are coming from inside of
your own [ __ ] house right women who
will
for the most part presumed i would guess
if you were to do a survey of women they
would think that slut-shaming
anti-abortion rhetoric and body shaming
mostly comes from men
it doesn't it comes from women and guys
like most of the guys that are having
the piss taken out of them about the way
that they look are about how strong they
are about how noodly their arms are and
stuff but
it's not girls that are saying that it's
your bros it's your bro friends or the
people that aren't even your friends
right like
that's where the vast majority of
attention but this gender war thing that
we've got that's going on at the moment
it gets clicks right because it creates
an easy in-group and out group you know
maybe after race it's the most prevalent
in and most obvious in group and out
group that there is
yeah and then you know you would you
would assume that is part of like the
you know the non-binary discussion as
well you can create in-group outgroup
easily there well there's a million
different in-groups in our groups if you
do that look see let's bring this one
home man uh people want to keep up to
date with the [ __ ] that you're doing
where should they go
uh please go to my youtube channel um i
discuss things all all things fitness
a little bit of a you know a focus on
olympic olympic-style weightlifting but
i try to focus on general fitness
my instagram coach underscore zt if you
want programming
uh i have general programming i have
squat programming for what you want to
do in the gym go to patreon.com
zachtelender and i think
that's it
that's all
that's it man
for the cameras
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you